I'm going to show you how to
take this old dresser drawer
and turn it into a garden.
NWA: (SINGING) Express yourself.
I'm expressing with
my full capabilities.
There is no end to the
bounty of mother nature.
There's enough for everybody,
and that's the one thing
that you will learn
from gardening.
Most importantly, what
I'm going to teach
you is how to grow
your own food.
(SINGING) Legendary.
Whoa.
In this class what
you going to learn
is how to take some of my
favorite vegetables and herbs
from planting to harvesting,
mint, lettuce, sage,
sweet potatoes, rosemary, kale.
I know a lot of
people out there,
you don't like leafy greens.
I don't either.
Put them in your diet,
anyway, because this
is one of the healthiest things
that you can possibly eat.
You're going to
learn how to make
the most of any patch of soil,
from sidewalks to roof tops
to flower pots.
And I know you're asking,
what the hell is compost?
Compost is one of the
sexiest things on the planet.
This takes things out
of the waste cycle.
They don't wind up
in the landfill.
(SINGING) Things ain't
never going to be the same.
These things are
really important,
not only to your garden,
but to the planet.
(SINGING) Are you ready?
Are you ready?
I call myself the
gangster gardener,
'cause to me having
knowledge is gangster.
Soil is gangster.
Air is gangster as [BLEEP].
(SINGING) Make way for me.
Gardens to me
represent freedom.
That's one of the reasons that
I started growing food myself.
And I had no idea what happened
in my community,
then around the world,
would happen just
from me planting a strip in
South Central Los Angeles.
(SINGING) Legendary.
Are you ready?
We are supposed to inspire
each other to wake up an--
and realize what's
truly important.
I want to bring your
creativity into your space.
I want you to know that you
have the power to do this.
(SINGING) Legendary.
I'm Ron Finley, and
this is my MasterClass.
(SINGING) Wait and see.
Wait and see.
They going to talk about me.
Just wait and see.